we're asked which of these lines are
parallel so they give us three equations
of three different lines and if they're
parallel then they have to have the same
slope so all we have to do over here is
figure out the slopes of each of these
lines and if any of them are equal
they're parallel so let's do line a line
a it's 2y
is equal to 12 x plus 10. we're almost
in slope-intercept form we can just
divide both sides of this equation by
two let's divide all the terms by two
we get y is equal to 6 x right 12
divided by 2
6 x plus 5. so our slope in this case we
have it in slope intercept form our
slope in this case is equal to
6.
let's try line b
line b
is y is equal to 6. now this might be
you might say hey g this is a bizarre
character how do i get this into slope
intercept form where is the x and my
answer to you is that it already is in
slope-intercept form i could just
rewrite it as y is equal to 0x plus 6.
the x term is being multiplied by 0
because the slope here is 0. y is going
to be equal to six no matter how much
you change x change in y is always going
to be zero it's always going to be six
so here our slope is zero
our slope is equal to zero so these two
lines are definitely not parallel they
have different slopes so let's try line
c
line c i'll do it down here
line c
so that's y minus 2 is equal to 6 times
x plus two and this is actually in point
slope form where the point
what the point x is equal to negative
two y is equal to two so the point
negative two two
is being represented here because you're
subtracting the points and the slope is
6. so we already know that the slope is
equal to 6. and sometimes people are
more comfortable with slope intercept
form so let's put it in slope intercept
form just to confirm that if we put it
in this form form the slope will still
be equal to 6. so if we distribute this
6 we get y minus 2 is equal to 6 times x
6x plus 6 times 2 is 12. and then if you
add this 2
if you add 2 to both sides of the
equation
you get
y because these guys cancel out is equal
to 6x plus 14. so you see once again the
slope is 6. so line a and line c have
the same slope so line a and line c are
parallel and they're different lines if
they had the same y intercept then they
would just be the same line